okay so we're going to break into the
cult and get our little bro back and we
found our mom again didn't me let me
know if you want me to like rearrange
audio whatever as well
[Music]
I should like to know maybe oh I love
smelly can
[Music]
skree teacher
or you can say yeah
so a police car in the game am I going
crazy I might be going
Karen
Karen it's a Karen thanks we gotta be
careful now
if anything happens let me do the
talking okay yeah of course let's get
this over with
it seems to be some lag so I apologize
for that now so you know okay you sure
Lisbeth we'll have those files on your
sister [ __ ] how many
Donnie
thanks you weren't supposed to come and
go further in the church was the
services over mom of this kid lived over
in that land I felt like if we go with
the man and this kid he might be um so
he might behavior distracted by his kid
community back east wouldn't was both
came out here to start leave employment
folks fall and brought me along yeah
there's the woman that must have been
hard on you kinda late girls don't want
to go to church on it
sorry Reverend he won't be hiding behind
that cross for much longer
Oh be careful son yeah see he's just
busy the service is over so what are you
still doing yeah I know Derek I was just
showing him around
Oh
sorry
we have to go
to get caught no sorry I wasn't really
thinking but there's like only one like
well there's two ways around here and I
thought he might be you know distracted
by a his there it is looks empty
let's hope so Oh unless I was supposed
to go through the actual place
how are those doors are closed heritage
it says the last episode is probably in
the live streams uncut playlist
untwine make sure you look through the
window I'm gonna be really reckless
no one's in sight good okay what about
this window can I bet see that one
can't believe Danny really lives in mr.
present house okay I just I hope they're
not on to us let's haul ass
where are the files right there in her
office oh of course it's locked her
open-door speech it's just nothing wrong
I've got to find a way in
[ __ ] I think there's a key somewhere
maybe she's too cautious not to have a
spare set around
whoa
Wow are you okay Jake yeah no it's just
so full of memories and stuff
and load and the bee
antibiotics for a yeast infection at
vulva stress and anxiety Elizabeth Oh
what does it mean didn't she say she
like never get sick or something because
she was picked by God or something like
that it's maybe it means she's lying
I mean she is not lying anyway she's a
liar this place is worse than Barney
make bed every morning clean dishes
after every meal Viking Pole and room
weekly take out trash on Monday wash
hair every two days help with Sunday
laundry count your blessings daily poor
Daniel I mean at least he's got a
routine I guess he's been missing that
get Daniel's big nose
and I thought Clarence Stephen World
fashioned
what are you looking at and didn't get
there some shoes this is so hard maybe
Daniel did it confine and convince 15
study units in here must be so much fun
Lizbeth sure likes to be on pictures
I like our new must be weighted break it
oh yeah
pirate look more button the bin I want
to break it we're looking for another
set keys aren't we oh okay so I'm
guessing we could use that to break here
might be enough to open that door nope
I'm not gonna break it I'm gonna look
for the keys they've got to be here
somewhere
Damon's haircut makes much more sense
now
this is a lot of pills yeah this but a
specially for someone who doesn't
believe in science
oh yes that's true it's for her anxiety
way and thrush was it
nothing here Jesus is a friend of mine
yes we're trying to get into her office
key is it that right wonder okay I found
a key
what a great [ __ ] family [ __ ]
don't see anything of interest wait does
she smoke not guys now what Jesus wants
you to dope the kicked her out of church
now they're thirsty whoo
this isn't Michael bloom and I know it's
been a long time since we last talked
and I know that our talk was not a happy
one despite our differences we all knew
you were devout spirits to be reckoned
with nobody has been surprised by your
words and deeds touching so many people
I hope you believe it when I say we're
all part of you but what also sorry and
ashamed for asking you to leave the
church without understanding the power
of your faith as we need to remind
ourselves with six and me life lessons
even prideful deacons should be humbled
before laws wisdom I hope you find in
your heart speech wait
to
why did they do that then what does she
do
wait who's that that's the one I stupid
doesn't it oh they kicked her out of
church mm-hmm now they're thirsty she
sure likes to gaze at her own success
just bit narcissistic pretty isn't she
yeah that will definitely explain what's
going on with Daniel
okay what done she's completely obsessed
with his power hmm can you play the
prequel from Chloe before the storm
yes I have played that one it's on the
channel somewhere somewhere okay if 196
sona's pop in and say hi thanks but tom
in daniel tired after using gift nothing
gives some energy after new diet he acts
on his own Scripture won't impelled him
more prayer more study Daniel Powter
today after lessons spare the rod and
spoil the child not yet most sure grace
trust in the Lord I did cry today
watching the miracles the child must be
a vessel what will he deliver unto us
and when she is playing way too much
pressure on that kid you know the bed
nice prison dude
nothing interesting okay well at least
we're not gonna break airlock so if she
comes back and by some miracle doesn't
realize we're here and teach to a new
hotness then we might have an upper hand
it's this damn lesson
oh yeah man
it's depressing well Elizabeth doesn't
believe in material possessions so
doesn't mean you need to decorate your
house no play box no play box
I'm not surprised he kept that ugly
thing he was so glad when he found it
this is still bad another ugly white
shirt she's making him wear
let's get all of his possessions so he
doesn't get oh I wish she said a blanket
from dad she doesn't lose anything if we
have to just run out quickly hey Cedric
Rahul what website is down is it the
just giving one it was down a few weeks
past as well he looks happy [ __ ] can't
believe I missed it
it's not an assignment as she forcing
him to do this
why is he accepting all that
oh he's like writing to repent
happy birthday Daniel
happy birthday Daniel not that one this
[ __ ]
people are really all over his power
juice Daniel I know you may never read
this but I had to reach out after
witnessing your Holy Spirit last week
I'm a sinner I have not been a
church-going woman for years but it
heard a story from my neighbor about
Elizabeth fish and your miracles I could
feel the Lord whispered to me and when I
drove all the way from the Truckee to
Haven point when I saw your angel face
I knew my faith was coming back you
showed us the God is alive and working
through Daniel you raised the cross like
he raised Jesus I found my faith again
and I'm more strong than ever you were
sent to prove that God's love is real
I'm saving money to see you again
and I pray I can be a service forever
how much money is it just to see Daniel
because if this woman has to save up
money it's supposed to be about God like
I thought going to church and stuff was
free
oh my gosh it's Finn's bracelet what's
this drawing
Oh Daniel so hasis happy mrs. Fang
what a waste can I not pick that up as
well The Book of Daniel
so much for hot dog man I Daniel was
troubled in spirit and the visions that
pass through my mind disturb me I
approach one of those standing there and
asked him the meaning of all this so he
told me and gave me the interpretation
of these things the four great beasts
are four kings that will rise from the
earth but the holy people of the most
high will receive the kingdom and will
possess it forever
yes forever and ever okay weird she
doesn't think that it's like Daniel from
the Bible we incarnate on something does
she I mean I wouldn't professor she's
crazy
this is quite the change from power
bearing friends how long has he been
there for I didn't think it had been
that long like a month or something
I think this is a travel class no oh
okay man cause I'm short uh-huh yeah no
I don't think she's like asking for
people to pay but there's definitely
that the tip box isn't there but yeah
you might be right that she might be
seeing up money to come visit again
locked of course I have the key
shaped maybe it opens the other door
yeah okay
Jesus has ever mine mitosis again so she
doesn't know
there was nothing in here problems
pillows volume Owen and the scissors I
can't use them
okay I'm comment
yes that's the one hey clay
it's this her personal archive or
something yeah she keeps track of
everything in here stuff about my sister
must be in this one
okay I've got something
what easy must be what you're looking
for
she has pneumonia
his sister for what I get Elizabeth
knows damn well she needs medical
treatment that's criminal she's in the
same luck she has a file on YouTube you
can take a peek and see how she really
treats her flock man what's all this
were you like sick
conversion therapy today
I wanted to cure you from being
wait pretty much I always showed more
interest in boys than girls well that
sucks
didn't you
tell your parents he's kidding
they wanted her to do that mom and dad
thought I had a demon inside so that I
really did believe I was a sinner
somebody thought I had to atone for my
sins
yeah well since yeah
no strings no things for what sins I
don't get how they can preach this kind
of crap
I mean you vent Finan everyone are they
sinners then of course that I just
didn't know different Sean yeah yeah I
know them I just want you to know now
after a few years I was in a really bad
place I I tried to hurt myself
Elizabeth was very upset we had a long
chat she told me I should leave
though see the world and figure things
out I don't really get hurt Sean
Elizabeth does believe in all this stuff
I had no clue about your life here
she of them I'm sorry Jacob Bates I'm
sorry I brought Daniel here I was just
so blown away when I saw what he could
do it was like a real miracle I thought
I'd I'd find my faith again
instead like I just heard him
no it's okay
we'll make this right but let's make
things right we just have to get Daniel
out of here I hope so and I'll get my
sister to a hospital yes ever treated
keep my money for your sister
she needs oh I can't do that Shawn that
that's a lot of wear okay it will cover
her medical bills
Wow Thank You Shawn
maybe I should have done that oh well I
mean he's this is gonna die without it
right this guy is dangerous Sean
oh I trust them um yeah see what you can
do Sean well there's a mouth a bath
water up there up close not good
hide under Jess what am i doing why into
there that makes sense what we're gonna
hear
okay well [ __ ] it like this big covet no
no no what a gold Nikolas I thought he
was cousin ha you are always trouble
I'll deal with you later
Shay come with me really do play Oh
let your power speak through this young
vessel speak to me Reverend
Shawn what's going on Reverend she was
going through your stuff in your office
Jacob let him in but I took care of that
Judas all Shawn little lost lamb
how could you desecrate Holden Shawn you
okay huh yeah don't worry
come with me Daniel we're leaving please
I know I'd only messed up she's full of
[ __ ] dude and she's using you Daniel has
made his choice shown that I'm offering
you to join us Eddie put your faith in
me and you'll be family never so that's
your final decision may the lord have
mercy on your lost crap wait Kanaan time
for you to leave Irish mob right no not
without my brother didn't you hear the
Reverend Nicholas sean is just confused
we forgive the sinners I'm not going
anywhere this is my home
she's my family now Daniel listen she's
not your family Sean who is she she's
your mama she came for you oh praise the
Lord
another miracle at our church wonderful
it's all right Daniel go see her I mean
she's right there don't be afraid I you
don't know her of course I know this is
hard for you my son stop calling him
that
you're just manipulating him sicko
that's in the eye of the beholder but
since you are his mother let me ask you
how could you
a child wander alone in the wilderness
where were you when Daniel was lost
where listen Daniel I came here as soon
as I found out you were here on your own
I'm not on my own children are a gift
from the Lord they are really there like
this lady shuttle and you cast him out
into the world and looking at the
comments like everyone's the same
abandoned another woman who also gave up
your rights
is it your God all about clay said
something else play set sail frame ps2
about no phase a game how can you have
seen it does look like a great game
these two children you left them and
your husband to seek out your base
desires annual honey she's just trying
to trick you please think about yourself
now that you had that capture card I can
play PSP games next time I go down to my
mom's house I'm gonna get slow the ps2
games so we're gonna play some waitress
about that's gonna be great injustice
pain I'm just so sorry Danny
I know I know how much I hurt you and
your brother bite me I know it's not
enough yeah I've already given her a lot
of steak for that to be fair we can talk
about it together that's what I've been
trying to tell you brother
and I'm so glad he listened
you gotta trust us she's using me for
her selfish desires Daniel this time the
choice is yours
are you going to believe her or me can
you please stop touching him and like it
knows me touching him - Daniel from this
garden you'll stay with us yes but you
haven't even let him go never leave him
go to hell
but now don't you understand this is
over Jean you have to talk to him you
can convince him
okay module is the power of completion
don't be so stubborn Sean your brother
chose his path
no Charlie she's very sick she's got the
narrow mirror to a doctor ramonja Daniel
knows who to trust
I know she went to see doctors for
herself when she was in pain she never
waited for a miracle when she was in
danger what
there's the pills those pills in the
bathroom have you not seen them faith in
me Daniel I know what I'm doing
God is speaking to me and to you
basically mr. tete Sabine we are in a
cult
trying to get our brother back oh I got
an itchy back okay um mmm-hmm I need to
say she was killed here she was kicked
out of the church they knew she was
crazy so she left and found in Haven
Point I love a greatcoat liar I left on
my own because they were all blind don't
believe his lies Daniel
she's get mad see
[Music]
I've seen your homework Daniel copping
lines over and over how can you accept
that this is worse than school do it no
it's nice see what you have done
hey you know back off
no one is gonna keep me away from you
I said stop I don't know if I made the
right choices
I didn't wanna don't use the dad against
get up came all this way for you and
nobody will stop me I'll even cross hell
whatever if I look there hard thing your
brother like can you know can you not
see I'm gonna spam it listen
I did my best job to be a good brother
and I know I probably failed took you
for granted
and I'm sorry don't listen to him he
left you just like that harlot did
Collis that um could hit me as much as
he wants
I won't give up a drug don't let them do
that Daniel
this man could go back in time I would
we've been are living Seattle
that would get his pizza
and snacks then pick the movie because
we would always fight about it he always
picked your movie
but I can't do that all I can do now is
buy quiet what are you waiting for
we're the best team and I know that's it
happy going for what are you gonna kill
him please
he's my broken burned down our church
but not our faith Daniel knows you're
telling the truth don't give up
come on I just don't want to get shot
nothing is gonna stop me
brother
did obviously
our blood leak was the most important
Daniel listen to him
come on Daniel like look if he's trying
his best and he survived even hit right
he isn't resorted to violence Oh back
again
Daniel come on
see he wants to come don't move
just stop if you want to kill me then do
it
I'm not afraid do it shoots dial go
ahead let's shoot eat the faith
now
don't save me
Shawn no crazy lady
so
I was so confused touching someone else
I'm sorry
Shawn we need to go
and then this fire consumed the mod left
in her hell no you started this fire you
will all burn in this hell
No let us go move it you won't leave
this place not with me alive not with me
alive
well what do I do
no I'm not I'm gonna I'm not going to
use Daniel why would I do that
oh I don't want to show you either shy
you can't threaten me with death I
embrace it I know
don't do it don't do it
oh I don't want to shoot I'm not gonna
shoot her
I cannot shoot her because that would
just be so traumatic for Daniel but oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
yeah yeah no like I'm not gonna shoot
her right even Oh
yeah see okay good as long as he didn't
kill huh
and they didn't force him to do that and
it's fine okay that's good
you're chairman format it's disgustin
yeah don't worry Gabrielle up in we
didn't kill her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you fake
[Applause]
[Music]
well but Jacob [ __ ]
question
oh thank god okay good
that's Sunday
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
this world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
that's it's a [ __ ]
[Music]
okay well while we're here we might as
well start on the next episode which is
the final episode and why the hell not
let's do this oh wait but also we can
see what choices everyone else mode the
burning thing was pretty Kari I agree
just you know no pig's blood
[Music]
the that little buddy now has a lot of
mental partners because of this woman
yeah I'm sure a lot of people have
enough mental problems with this of that
woman crazy this is what I really like
about life is strange that they do
tackle a lot of real hard-hitting but
very relatable topics that shipping
should be explored in video games I feel
so I mean obviously the obvious one in
this series anyway is racism because
they're both Mexican and they're trying
to get there in America trying to get
past the border and there's a lot of
like racism that they have to go through
that I would never have expected and
then because you know I'm a white girl
what though I know and and then
obviously just now like hearing about
Jacob being gay and basically being told
he was a sinner sucks
I can't imagine I can't imagine like
feeling wrong just because of like who I
love that's for any weird or what I'm
attracted to a yes
we used to do like electric compulsive
therapy right ECD for people who are gay
oh wait I can sleep I can leave you pass
both vision tests only 31% of people did
that hell yeah but I don't know if
people we did that on purpose actually
because maybe they thought they could
stay there for a bit longer if they
failed the test which it's not my idea
you told agent Flores the robbery was
Finn's idea yeah why wouldn't I don't
like that guy
until my there dude he's dead now anyway
um not like he deserved to die he didn't
deserve to die
but I still don't really like who he was
you escaped the hospital well hurting
anyone Oh what could've done convinced
you it you could have convinced Joey
you attacked Joey why would I do that
Joey so nice he can attack a guard yeah
I don't do that Tim wasn't at the
hospital I executed him Oh what people
could have saw was a thin ah he talked
to Finn and forgave him for what
happened
dab a boo-boo Danny Boy plays
yeah I agree months has it it's really
difficult to portray topics like this in
video games or in any form of media
because people are always worried about
like patterning it wrong but the Last of
Us seems to do it very well and I think
maybe because it's it's more of like a
linear story format instead of you know
it's not a game where like they have
loads of random interruptions and stuff
like that so maybe that's got something
to do with it because they can just make
sure that they're one linear story with
a couple of branches are all done well
and executed in you know in a format
that isn't going to cause too much
problems I don't know but yeah I think
it's important to take the risk and at
least talk about it I mean the last of
us to did that as well right they have
the trans character and I know some
people were saying stuff about that but
my I know some people who are part of
that community and part of the lgbtq+
and they actually you enjoyed the
representation not because it was nice
because they had to go through a lot of
hard stuff but it was true to what
people actually have to get it so
why I'm talking about hard topics you're
never going to please everyone i but
it's important because it helps
especially in video games where you
actually do you you have player agency
and you feel like you're the person that
you're playing us it's for me it's like
one of the best ways that i've really
understand situations that i would never
really get to be in in the real world
maybe the second closest thing would be
a book I feel like a film or TV show is
way to passes yeah if it died in my
story
he broke down this toy while taking it
out from Chad no I broke the door I just
wanted oh no all right dad yep
I refused to sing got into antal
instructors reach oh ten percent didn't
do that you gave money to the church you
didn't give me yeah I'm not gonna give
money to shake a JD Church it's shady
Church you cut the conversation short
with Karen overall you tried to let
Karen open up to you most people did
that that's quite nice you supposed to
see where Karen who stayed outside with
Karen when she's maids you didn't stay
outside you accept occurrence help yeah
why wouldn't I you got Nicolas
suspicious when sneaking into Haven
point Nicholas was unaware how could I
have I guess you might I should have
gone through the church itself you
showed your money with Jacob
you didn't give anyone a superb Jacob
most people did that shared the money
got caught by Nicolas managed to hide
yeah I got caught that was a stupid I
got away with did they okay kukuku
who's been tim was like hard to explain
it was we're on the road he was someone
that we met he was a bit of a douchebag
what do we do now make our way across
you ready yeah although at the border
through the Mexican border but are they
not with their mom anymore
we're at the board
[Music]
[Music]
yes then was um someone who tried to use
Daniel to steal some money which was
wild why there were two morph brothers
they lived in peace two hunters took
their dad
wolf brothers wondered for days nights
learning how to live on your own for the
first time that's when the Big Brother
discovered that the little is not an
ordinary
but a super-simple Olaf he decided to
head south to the distant land of their
ancestors the journey was long and
dangerous
still the wolf brothers be new friends
on the way they learned more about the
world but danger is huge I always follow
them after a bad accident
they were separate the big brother had
Bernard in the hunters finally captured
it could him in a cage but when he
finally escaped he went to search for
his little brother his soon found out
that the little wolf joined a coyote
cuffed and he would coyote kill after
all that she said she came to help
rescue him they back to the coyote
leader but she would not move east
he was their Idol
so they had to knock her out
to escape
the wolf brothers now reunited followed
their Hogan of far into the desert 200
does cool image
yeah there you go guys now you will call
up some what's happened
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
my job Shawn he doesn't have that stupid
haircut anymore what what time is it
yeah it's so beautiful
check it out
don't go too close to the edge so yeah
okay good call
that's amazing
I know
mr. I okay yeah it just itches
it's okay
I promise
mmm no matter what happens you hear me
yeah I love you too
[Music]
we got a cute it's a relationship
yo Diaz brothers always
[Applause]
so are you still having those bad dreams
you know about Lizbeth yeah sometimes I
feel like she's around coming after me
scared no he is scarred by hands
I don't worry mr. Tetsu been I'll
changed
I'm not gonna change the tale
um she's lucky she's lucky she's lucky
you didn't go out get her yeah that's
true yeah he could hurt someone creeps
me out
listen
or far away from him okay we're together
again safe
where's the mom where is the man was she
Sean she wasn't just like randomly
taking off again she she must be so much
[Music]
no one of they said anyway did exactly
what we had to four cops catchers will
be judged for what we did that's for
sure we didn't like killers so you know
we would be if we killed her
well we're almost at the board
I like it here but
we'll have to leave soon
I know I'm sorry you know Shawn
I know it's been a long time can you
tell me the rest of the wolf story
Oh
yeah I think you tell me pin forever
since we left off wait too long hmm
let's see
oh yeah okay so thanks to the remark the
wolf brothers barely escaped from the
peyote cult she let them to her secret
lair deep in the red desert
the wolf brothers rested for a while at
some point they'd have to continue their
journey south he's basically just
telling them exactly what they're doing
right now sir
okay tween Vanette their destination
lies a mighty fire you know what what
she shoes so they become friends excuse
me who's telling the story you are but
it's my story too right
yesterday I'm not gonna be a Greg this
is mine yeah that's true okay then so
what happens next
they they arrive in Mexico but while due
to the fire unicron boys together
the wolf's in the unicorn managed to
snow okay okay and become heroes the
police forgives them and all their
friends from the Mexico to celebrate
well that would be nice yeah sounds
pretty good and I know let's back this
[ __ ] up and head back to town
gotta clean up our secret pretty in this
place is to freedom
I hope we could go watch the stars again
mom said there's a moon eclipse coming
up soon okay so she's around I don't
know where she is
maybe she's sleeping someone Hey
I can help just tell me what you are in
the moment let's draw a little bit for
us
I'm glad you can still drive
you know me too young but if I can see
it in my mind I can still sketchy
almost that's so cool I don't want you
to stop drunk thanks man
this is so cool
hey can you draw me as a superhero like
striking a pose over the 10 hmm I can
try
do badass
fat-ass that is it wash day finished let
me check it out I just I like evil okay
evil
[Music]
pretty useless with a crazy one like we
had but it scares the Coyotes away oh
yeah activate flashlight
on the way
you know captain can can you take these
away
sure
perfect formation
let's clean up this mess not if it
cleans up by itself stop Daniel can't
catch it huh
no [ __ ] no good
every star looked the same until we used
Karen's old type book
I swear touted the same book in the
garage yeah I think he did why did he
never show it to us maybe reminded him
of Karen with more on too much oh hey
Ron yeah
well let's hit the trail cowboy
they're not gonna clean up after
themselves
I saw a water bottle up there it really
irritates me when I go walking up
something in the forest and I see a
bunch of rubbish what are you doing oh
don't do that
what the [ __ ] dude don't do that what's
wrong
stop messing with it man yeah do eagles
eat scorpions no idea cool let's go
teach you to be nice to all the little
creatures
see I wanna pick up that ball
well
Hey we saw the Milky Way indeed how cool
is that
yeah that's true and once that was so
cool Arthur and Stanley let us use the
telescope yeah
these guys are real cool
it looks very nice
didn't Joanne will let me help over the
sculpture when we get back
hell yeah here like the magic assistant
so we in like a civilization now not
hide it yeah
Karen was right there all cool with him
yeah I got my power why do you think
she's
to feast like what do you mean
she's my mom
you know I could have done it by myself
great hey let me be the cool helpful big
brother I think I just miss the rest of
that conversation about the Mambo oh
yeah
can you scared it
looks like a job for our local super
psychic boy
so maybe you can help us get out of here
I'll try step back be super careful
hey JC Wow Dan there you go I hope it's
okay nice man
so this is where a mum all that mum was
staying all this time as well I guess
well not all this time she was traveling
right I guess she might have been here
recently at least to know everyone there
cool it's a little scarecrows a 10
scarecrow go for it
I have to bring back the telescope to
Stanley and Arthur
went to town for weekly supplies some
pancakes left in the kitchen oh hell
yeah
I won't come pancakes
Danny will you copy I have a pancake
alert in the kitchen
repeat pancake alert ten-four
no flying pancakes today well I mean I
can still have the pancakes could end up
I must still have the pancake Karen must
have been so excited to find him oh yeah
so she she writes and she fly by night
not by Fri into the big city by stop
that cliche never dying in the steel of
the buildings the walk of the street but
no matter what or where I spin the pole
of a million dead poet's takes me to
dance once again go but this time I get
to lead until the next light
he was beaky why do I need that is that
a computer what doesn't think that I
need to put it in I'm getting comfy in
my [ __ ]
she's really good at rewriting whole
life I'm a solo mobius strip just when I
reached the end I go back to the
beginning resign myself to new faces the
privilege to escape and rewrite another
draft goddess laughs at plants then
shows me the page left and marked four
years out of the ghost death at the
seeds returner suppling to reveal their
Asian power now I go back forward laid
with fear and hope to watch the children
of the Sun this one's pretty intense
don't believe I would find a soul within
or without Church a miracle was sleep
and food and fought a day without [ __ ]
until it was not now we run two
celestial spires over visions of the
faith prophet engulfed an ego and belief
as the burning cross falls on all your
cord angels
I am the bonfire vanities so when the
dam breaks we also add like glass on a
mirage if I believe well it's got
something to do with finally Daniel in
that church where is your expensive
gaming chair I don't have one I mean I
don't know how much
I hope Karen since this declares to you
hi mom and dad I've been thinking about
this for a while and I know it's been a
long long time coming so I'm sitting
here tonight thinking about the words I
should have written ten years ago you
always used to say everything happens
for a reason we fought parted them I
understand why now there was a reason I
feel like I have to reach out to you
both tonight from the desert I know
you've only heard from me once by phone
and six times by the letters for almost
a decade I'm sorry I didn't mean to hurt
you and I was certainly not trying to
punish you like you told me don't laugh
but I just didn't know what did I say
all right poets block just like how you
had to block me from your life after I
left Esteban that's that dad I guess I
understand that's how you had to deal
with a problem child and only chance who
didn't live up to your expectations
there's no denying that I failed you but
the bread and weight of pure aspirations
as parents failed me too and you had
such a rigid opinion of what I was
supposed to be that I just didn't have
the chance opportunity to explore who I
was you wanted a daughter to grow up
happy finding a job and great husband
sets it down to breed have kids and
raise them in faith to continue the
cycle of suburbia that daughter wasn't
me I know that you were raised in a
different time and culture so I didn't
understand your point of view like you
didn't understand your wayward daughter
maybe a bridge too far for us at the
time after Danny was born you knew I
wanted to take a break sometime to
figure things out in my head and heart
it didn't make sense to you your view or
dad I get that but you didn't see how I
was so desperate and only Esteban was
willing to give me that time because he
saw how unhappy I was I don't blame you
for my decision to leave and maybe a
timeout would have led to some outcome
to the same outcome we will never know
and I try not to live in regret my life
has been a roller coaster and there have
been times I long to hear your voices
and thoughts even the negative ones and
I know when I last talked to you in New
York to ask for help and paying back my
debts you wanted to help but it was on
your condition to return right back to
where I couldn't return I hate that I
hate that was our last conversation I'm
sorry I reached out to you this day I am
sorry I broke your hearts I'm sorry I
let you break mine for silencing me for
so long I think we paid our dues I now
and now I sit under blue field a crystal
stars like a poet I am writing and
waiting for a chance to rebuild an old
bridge with my mother and father I hope
we can cross it one more time oh that's
cute I mean I still don't fully agree
with what she did
leaving her kids so the other day for
you if you want to live a life full of
adventure and being selfish which
there's nothing wrong with that at all
don't make the choice to have kids you
know but yeah but then again I'm not
I've never been in that situation so I
don't know but yeah it's a bit when you
have a kid and then you kind of let them
know in one way or another that they
were never really wanted it does it
makes it urine leaves a mark on them
either Karen was desperate for a job how
do i working with kids
karen has been camping in their own
house as we arrived there's a little
cactus at Sakura
it's a pancakes pancakes and hot sauce
and drown the pancakes and hot sauce Oh
interesting interesting perhaps he
canvassed his birthday was in Daniels
Big Ten late birthday party uh-huh
so they had another party for them Karen
have in common their love for pancakes
nice we've had our breakfast cam looks
so young and fragile on this picture
hard times Mikey looks like they all
finally found a home hmm
oh it's a letter from Jacob's sister I
doing okay i Lashon sorry I didn't write
to you sooner but this was the first
time I've had a chance to relax after we
got out of Haven point thanks to a new
brother I still can't believe it really
happened
so bizarre certainly and I do miss our
parents but we're not ready to let them
know where we are yet we'll figure that
out later
but the money you gave me I could play a
month's rent in advance or a room in a
small beach town on the coast Cerrone
loves it she's much better now thanks to
the antibiotics and we're doing great
the most important thing to me is my
sister just like your brother you're
lucky to have each other
and we're blessed when you both came our
way I'm trying to track down our
Humboldt crew so I'll keep you posted
ah the crew from the forest that's cool
we'll be cool Oh Gabriela's eating some
delicious dark chocolate I love dark
chocolate and sea salt so nice so good I
hope everyone is okay after the night in
the farm we will deserve a break in a
bad future do you let me know when you
make it to the other side you ain't done
you've got this give a little hear a big
hug oh wait I'm so glad so cute oh it's
Sarah Lee she looks like Lila has some
competition oh hi Daniel hope you're
good and happy I feel so much better now
I'm so happy I got to see the ocean for
the first time even try desert I think
that could be good at it I wish you were
here so here to the beach even if the
water's cold I love this weather way
more than the heat please come see us
soon thanks for being one of my best
friends that's young
but adorable Tonya's got a little girl
band um okay so what from the USB oh I
should have gone through that flash
drive weeks ago whose is this I totally
forgot does any remember where we got
this USB key from is that our old one it
must be our old one
hey Dad
come on like second
naima always knew how to crack me out
whoa
I should have gone there cat ready check
anything else out here darn it okay
alright let's let's spy on our mom no
clue there was a network of sea pirates
Karen's a real life hacker can takes on
some small piece works for a living
thanks for your last advice column we
got quite a response and a lot of hits I
know you don't want social media
footprint right you could generate a lot
of clicks with your insights okay so she
writes with some things as how she gets
I was thinking how does she get her
money
probably so good at describing painful
situations and seeing the good in to it
wait is that that dude that we saw ages
ago who gave us the dog
kisses you to Harlan
Oh
No
didn't realize how much I miss Cassidy's
voice and her song oh she's still
writing to him how does she know where
to send it though dude more than just a
song on a sexy boy no more city boy Jake
hook me up with your P o box okay she
already answered my question so now you
can't hide from your old crew anymore I
know you took off for the hospital and
I'm glad you're still going down to them
Mexico we've all been fugitives on the
run but you and Daniel are the kings of
the road I hope you finally get back
home of course I'm not ready to settle
yet so we're all hanging out in Colorado
the idea is trying to get as far away of
the west coast as possible too many
ghosts for now hard to believe Finn
isn't here to search it and we don't
miss him for that but he'll get a few
more songs out of me we all want to
remember him for his angels not his
demons I miss you I would love to take a
road trip out of this [ __ ] it'd be
great to swim with you it again sue
Byrne let me know when you hit Mexico
Sean don't make me take you down here I
leave and give you my number so no
excuses I hope we do get to see Cassidy
again she was really cool it's a VHS
tape yeah it was an absolute fan of this
movie chupacabras from outer space
together
got to keep my I leave Andy then I leave
cloud I don't need it as much so that he
sees it out you know what it is changed
my diapers but it's kind of awkward to
you yeah
mmm wish Karen didn't tell me she got a
rattlesnake out of the toilet last went
crazy
man I'm still not used to this heat up
here
hey retro pixel I'm enjoying that range
that's pretty good
what's not to like about it really I
mean I still prefer the first series
want a telescope back oh yeah
I think that's just because I can relate
to it more but I'm learning more stuff
in this one so it's isn't just in nice
verse 10 you'll never change
still can't believe she's captain oh wow
it's like an old present that he gave
her it's nice to play games that Daniel
again Karen likes to join us too
Karen Totten some cool off the grid
shape oh they're filtering them all so
that again that's cool
what's this discuss with who Hey do you
miss Beavercreek
they're lots of fun
just glad we still family out there yeah
excuse me waterboy did you remember to
feed the crops
[Applause]
oh yeah freaking row a lot of stuff you
can also try to be self-sufficient when
we're in Mexico
oh yeah we grow a lot about them yeah
cool
David always wants to help his trailer
we're looking forward to get off that
the key is key
I might have to go since I'm getting
tired
well no it's a night listen
okay know this from a thing
it seems like this place this huge part
of town okay Tony you invisible wolves
I should stay around here some of the
panels that's good
pretty smart you're never gonna run out
of Sun in the desert mm-hmm
that's cool
I'm looking at this place I see they
care and really wanted to get away from
it all
we helped Joanne set up this giant
vacuum with binoculars it's cool
I like it you can alien
it's so cool that people want to give a
second life to their stuff they have
stuff like this down in Cornwall they
put it like in post boxes and is usually
for books so you go in you put one of
your books down and you can like take
another out do I understand before okay
our tents done okay love the energy out
here with everyone building stuff as
they please
Jonah's RV movie theater dude remember
when you totally fell asleep doing that
Bollywood flick whatever you miss prions
danly teaching me how to dance
where's there's then there he is
no matter what happened before Karen did
hook us over here that counts hmm what I
want to look at junk Joanne can throw at
Oh a rager out of here
but without our own neighbors
maybe they're in here whitening guys now
let's go talk to them
hey what's up morning Sean join us have
a seat
ain't just in time for our special
desert brew and dust free thanks so much
Sean it's too early to be so awake no
kidding
hey how was your sleepover in the canyon
amazing hey watch the sunrise
Daniel loved it too that's my favorite
view out here it's like ancient times
but it never gets old unlike us darling
can you be here long after we're gone
hope you looked up we did thanks for
hooking us up anytime even my daughter
Becky loves to stargaze when she visits
us that's the only way to get Arthur to
camp now Becky is the wheel astronomer
in the family wonder where she got this
from her mom
probably hope you guys get to meet Becky
does she come visiting often not as much
as I'd want can't really blame her but
you know some parts of the year this
place is full of friends and family
Christmas for example
so don't you ever get bored being out
here is a big change we do sometimes
we're in the desert
I miss the parks cafes shopping but this
place is something else and we feel safe
out here you could have seen me as a
family man a few years ago I had
everything but nothing now I have
nothing but everything next to this one
keao after we got together we both had
serious breakdowns then we got the hell
out of a Bay Area for the better hear
that I'm just so [ __ ] tired of
running help me and Daniel find our own
way you will people come here to reset
their life become the person they wanna
be or used to be you're smart you'll
figure out your next direction right
Gramps
speak for yourself grandpa my body might
be 59 but I'm 25 remember that on the
next hike I'm gonna see what gang is up
to do look 59
hey doc ring schmuck I'm actually nearly
finishing the stream in a weird hippie
version some buyers huh you think they
picked this up at the gas station
what you're a little too young to be
stalking me dude
no I'm not enjoying normal for people in
love to kiss I'll be over in a minute
I didn't know he ever left gosh
you live in your own world that's what I
love about
Oh Daniel drew this guy's [ __ ] okay
your captain spirit drawing was awesome
that's just too sad yep let's make it
happen break
probably gonna hit another invisible
wall yeah what's this
thank you get used to I want to see I
want to see you down weird shell house
it looks super cool I
[Music]
no I wish Daniel wasn't the only kid in
town
yeah they could play Oh can we draw this
place is such a trip it's kind of like a
desert Mirage
if you think you can see it
but the closer you get it changes
I thought the people here would be like
freaks
but they're just sick of the [ __ ]
how I sound like local
I guess I'm always gonna be a visiting
nope let's see care for the pins like no
no it's okay you can go fish sleepy yeah
I will soon I'm just gonna explore a
little bit coming up
no I guess Cantrell he's just sitting
chilling
what's up Joanne see for yourself yeah
check this out hey Daniel let's take a
little break
got it
a child is something special yeah
here this one a lot don't worry mmm
yeah I bet Wow he was he supposed
Messiah I'm dead serious wait what did
she just say what did she just say I
don't even know she says thanks of
course you do only dumb asses think they
know everything
that's very true it's okay to not never
stop yes that's true
don't worry so much about the outcome an
artist has to take the leap of faith
about every other week
did you always want to be an artist good
grief no I tried very hard not to be one
till I realized it was useless listen
you want to be an artist
you will be it's not always easy
but in the end it's pretty [ __ ] cool
speaking of do you mind giving me a hand
here
oh I don't know if I can yes we can I
just need your input okay okay okay sure
why not
ah there you go Oh so Daniel like that
helps her with her ah bye you ready to
start again putting stuff
it's laces thank you bah bah so for my
next week I'd love to see if you can
connect these three pieces I've made a
model of what
in mind here but you go ahead you see
the artist and we don't need a crane to
lift this stuff Daniel can snap these
together like block toys oh yeah let's
do this
wait no shows it why why you like okay
there's a block a bowl why does he keep
moving I'm not doing this I'm not asking
him to me what the hell the game is bad
right
wait I need I need the box I guess it'll
be the bowl first then bull now I'm
sweating second I think maybe that's
supposed to represent the earth oh yeah
okay Daniel a ball change a bulb on
slam-dunked the earth ball onto the base
your legs stop moving I'm not doing this
that means that bits
I can't Anna
it wouldn't really be an appointment can
you turn that earth ball around a little
bit
[Music]
earth Bob Olivares what just like half a
turn
I don't know baby
how about working your magic on the ball
again
how is that okay let's put the arms on I
can get him to move now let's throw on
that spider
cool
the one going up is like to the left
yo can you turn that that spider thingie
around
no I don't running I be honest uh this
is put the head um now let's move mr.
pancakes head onto the pedestal
mhmmm is such a cute hat
so that one is like just to the left of
the head
hmm maybe give that spider another twist
yeah howdy
feel like we're almost done I wanted to
keep the same photo frame crux and neck
looks good to me
only if the music why not it's still
cool you did a great job in it well Sean
Daniel I think art might be in your
family DNA there is no escape I think
we're done for the day
thank you so much for your help okay I'm
gonna go down because also the game is
for talent bugged oh no its face no it's
not
she said my minecraft again after we
load the game next time he won't be
walking around all the time and I can
actually control him again um thank you
for spending your evening with me I well
be streaming again next week and yes as
I said before there is a video on the
way of me cutting my fringe so you can
get to see that it took me a long time
I'm not gonna lie I was I was a little
[ __ ] about it so anyway look out for
new videos also make sure to follow me
on Instagram because I don't know if you
were here when I was having my massive
rant earlier but I was talking about how
I wanted to share more of my unreal
cinematic progress on Instagram and a
might even be making a new Astrium
account mode
like gamedev stuff but either way I do
share a lot on there so make sure to
follow me on that and then also you can
follow me where your have tea yeah after
obviously but yeah you can follow me on
Instagram
that's how I spell it right at my
instance and there's a Twitter as well
and of course you can always join
discord where we chat and stuff and
you'll get announcements when I am
live-streaming so that's all the main
places that you might want to be if you
want to check up on what I'm gonna do
next yeah I'm gonna have to look into
seeing whether we can stream the ps2
once this is over because I would love
to play some old games to you guys and I
should be going to visit my family like
as soon as I can with all the stock
sound stuff so yeah that'd be really fun
like II can't I could get um I've got
Harry Potter
I still think Gregory hoar ship but I
already played that for you on this
channel I could play it again I got
other games are you I don't know which
ones I got Pressey Jackson's King Kong
well the gains of I got I got loads I
got Beyond Good and Evil so yeah we
could play some cool games together and
maybe I could play fatal frame if I can
find it and buy it clay
I see you I see your comment okay I'm
gonna leave doubt have a live a day or
evening thank you again for spending the
evening with me I'm going to say goodbye
hit 2 who I can see in the chat so
goodbye mantas goodbye Kerala goodbye
clay goodbye Jonathan
goodbye I look like crap and get Britt
is like no we have to we have to follow
you
also don't forget um you can search Yaga
monix on music streaming platforms if
you want to hear more music like stuff
that you were listening to at the
beginning of the stream so yeah check
check check it there down
goodbye retro pixel and goodbye to
anyone who is here but just isn't in the
chat really appreciate you being here as
always thanks for joining us like this
dream I'm gonna go now okay you're
needing RCA to HD my confessor I've got
so many comparators but don't worry I
will buy one if I don't have it